[Music]
this morning on the dish we take you to
england to meet a chef reviving a
british classic the savory pie
column franklin with his team at
london's holborn dining room at the
rosewood hotel craft phenomenal
creations designed to please both the
palette and the eye mts taeyab went to
meet the city's undisputed king of pies
behind these doors
is where british pie making is at its
most refined
chef callum franklin of the holborn
dining room located in the heart of
central london takes the crafting of the
traditional savory typically meat-filled
and pastry-wrapped parcels to a whole
new level
was any part of you worried about
i don't know if londoners want to eat
pies no
the native south londoner designed the
restaurant's pie room himself and filled
it with antique copper pie molds dating
back to the victorian era
celebrating a national food culture that
was first recorded over 600 years ago
and is still beloved by home cooks today
and actually so subconsciously it
transports you back to your family table
right simpler times
sat you know
getting abused from your brother and
sister at a dinner table it's an
a nice link to that part of your
childhood and we do that
whilst making it very elegant as well
did you need a room for it though 100
with the peak of its popularity during
the victorian era pies were fuel mainly
for the poor who could fill their
bellies for little more than a penny
nearly a century later pie and mass
shops remained a staple in working class
areas of south and east london but today
the traditional eateries are on the
brink of extinction a food history
franklin is trying to save
along with his number two knox majosi a
south african-born londoner who has
earned the title of master pie maker
growing up in south africa did you ever
think you'd be in a room like this in
london making pies
not at all
what does it make you feel when people
call you a master pie maker for me i
find like you know what for me this at
the end i find what i love the most it's
fills me with joy that you know what i'm
doing what i love now at the hoben
dining room the pies may cost a little
bit more than a penny but come filled
with carefully sourced ingredients like
the classic pork pie which is made of
hand raised pork shoulder smoked bacon
fennel seed and sage or the decidedly
french-inspired dolphinwa potato pie
made with winterdale english cheddar and
caramelized onion
all hand crafted and resembling edible
art images of which that have gone viral
thanks to franklin's wildly popular
instagram page
it was my wife who said to me you know
you should you should put something on
instagram you know this work you're
doing people are going to be interested
in
and i was like no one's going to be
interested in brown food
brown pies on instagram yeah and we
started to post stuff
and it just went wild
franklin who is toiled in some of
britain's finest kitchens knows a thing
or two about living the wildlife for the
first decade of his career he was in his
own words an alcoholic
your relationship with alcohol
became kind of a problem didn't they
yeah definitely so i went into rehab in
the end you know i how old are you
so i was
30.
drinking so much every day
and on the job he says he physically
couldn't stop
and in the end yeah it just
sort of primal instinct kind of must
have kicked in and one day i reached out
to my brother and said
i need help i need to go to rehab today
because i think i knew i was going to
die
and uh
he just said you know we've been waiting
for you to say this for
so so long
for franklin the savory pie soon became
something of a savior a taste from his
childhood he could elevate and perfect
for his diners
and then there's some chicken pie
chicken and
chestnut mushroom pie
classic british pie biggest seller on
the menu lots of peas
and some chicken gravy it's just
one of those flavors
right that you've just had your whole
life and yeah it's like a blanket yeah
and the crab thermador wrapped in pastry
i mean this
tastes like the sea
the one thing i should say is the pastry
so flaky
so good and so light as well that's
knoxy working
such supercharged flavors aren't always
associated with traditional british
cookery something franklin says he's
acutely aware of
as someone who thinks so deeply about
what you put on these plates every
single day
what do you want to do next
so really i would love to do this
but on a larger scale
and raise the whole pie game in the uk
so it really becomes back to being
something celebratory you know something
we all get behind and people are proud
of for cbs saturday morning empty house
time
london
that was good oh my gosh come to new
york with those works
that's why they're not here by the way
because they're so delicate and so
beautiful
you can't get them that far yeah saved
us on the diet right it did but that
would be awful and look good yeah
incredible